But we don't say the inje is the Bible.
I know you don't. We We never The angel
is the gospel that was with Jesus. Even
when you go even when you like do your
research when you go like is the injil
the Bible that we don't say the angel is
the Bible. Well, what is it then? If
it's not the Bible is what was what was
with Jesus. What was that?
It's God. It's God. It's God.
[Music]
What just happened? Oh, this is this is
Wait, did it record? Uh, we missed that
part. Oh my gosh, bro. He he said, you
know, he he slipped out of We don't say
he's he accidentally said he's when he
says that like he's divine prophet. Uh,
not divine, but not divine. Like we
don't say we don't say he's divine. We
just say he's a creation of this how God
created uh Adam. um he created him in a
specific way. Yeah. There will never be
a person created like Adam and there
will never be a person created like
Jesus. So when God says be, we say God
just says be and something comes to be.
So people say that I would argue that in
the Quran Jesus does have a a level of
divinity to him or um where would you
say um because like for example there's
like you're talking about there's
attributes and abilities that belong to
God alone. Would you agree? And like uh
creation, all this kind of stuff. Yeah.
Well, in the Quran it says that Jesus
created a bird from clay with Allah's
permission. Yeah. But he created that's
the key part. With Allah's permission.
So with our per like let's say I create
like a a like let's say I turn let's say
I create you know like a you turn that
into banana. Yeah. Let's say I turn that
banana and God lets me do it. God let me
he let the ability like I'll go with
you. So let's let's go with that. Allah,
you know, gave Jesus the well, it says
the permission to create this birth from
clay. So now Jesus is a creator of life
thanks to Allah giving him permission,
right? So now in in Islam, you have two
creators of life. But that's supposed as
well cuz we create like let's I can
create do you create life? We can't
create life. We can't. This is this is
something let's say me and a woman came
together. The the baby will come
together cuz God permitted it to be.
That's right. However, this one Jesus
did it. Yeah. With all with God's
permission. So, like everyone's a
creator. We're not
[Music]
creator of life. He's the ultimate
creator. He's the creator of all
creators. Is there another creator of
life though? A creator of life. No,
there is no Exactly. So, since all
there's only one creator of life, if
Jesus created life by God's permission,
now he is another creator of life with
Allah's permission. Like, we're also
creators though. You're not hearing what
I'm saying. I'm not talking about us
making things. I'm talking about
creating life. Okay? Like even the Quran
says if all the jin and the men in the
world get together, none of them will be
able to create. Boom. You got it. So
this is one of the evidences that Allah
is using against pagan idols and false
gods to show that he is the true god cuz
he's the creator of life. Nobody can
create life. So if Jesus creates life,
whether you say it's by Allah's
permission or not, but Allah's
permission, there's there's like you
said by Allah's permission, and that's
where it stops. Like, well, he's a
creator of life. Now, let's say let's
say God let uh what's your real name?
Avery. Avery. Let's say God lets Avery
um create an elephant right here. Yeah.
I'm now I'm a creator of life. Yeah, cuz
God let you do it. So now So now I I'm
But you're not the person who gave
permission. I'm No worries. I just
There's just now two creators of life.
Yeah. So if there's two creators of
life, you now destroy monotheism.
Uh, okay. You get the point. We Okay,
let's say if you destroy monotheism,
let's let's get into like I guess we can
switch like last topic for before for me
and him to start walking again. Okay.
Okay. So the trinity, right? Wait, do
wait. Do you do you agree that if
there's two creators of life that that
is no longer monotheism? No, because
it's there's a key to it by Allah's
permission. So let's say God, how I
explained it to you, like God So by
Allah's permission, he could create
other creators of life. Yeah. Because if
Allah's and if you're a creator of life,
you're not a god. No, because there's
the ultimate creator. The person who
gave you the permission. That's like you
being a that's like you being an
employee, right? And your boss lets you
do something and you say, "Oh, I'm the
boss." And like you know how No, but
let's let's say that let's say you're a
CEO, right? And then you make somebody
else another CEO. Like you give them all
the executive abilities of a CEO that a
CEO does. You give somebody else that.
So now they're a CEO with you. No, you
let them be the CEO, right? So you're
still above them. No, you guys are now
both CEOs. Let's
have the same ability. So now there's no
longer one CEO. Two CEOs of one company.
Yes, there actually can. There's
examples of that. Yeah. Two CEOs. Yeah,
there's co Yeah, there can't be two
CEOs. Yes, there there's literally
companies with co-CEOs, bro. A co.
They're called co. Yeah, that means with
they're not the real CEO. Like there's
somebody above like No, they're the
they're both co-CEOs. They run the
business together. But still, you know,
we're talking about God, right? I know.
That's what I'm pointing. He's still the
ultimate. Like, okay, if you want to say
that, let's let's go with it. Then
that's still not monotheism. That would
be hentheism. You're saying that there's
one ultimate, but then there's one under
the ultimate. So that but there's still
two, but there's one better. All right.
Let me ask you this though. So you say,
okay, you say you say Jesus is God,
right? Yes. And you say the son is God.
Jesus is the son. Okay. I mean, you say
the father is God. The father is God.
The son is God. The holy spirit. They're
not each other, right? They're not each
other. They're distinctive personhood.
Wait, when you say person, what do you
mean person? Uh underlying reality of a
rational nature. So meaning there there
is a a cognitive um self-awareness.
There's intellect, right? In personhood.
Would you say since they're not each
other, they would be I know Christians,
they don't like saying individuals or or
cuz you guys don't say that. You guys
like individuals? Yeah. Indiv individual
persons. Don't I don't have a problem
with that phrase. individual persons who
are not each other but one they're
distinct from each other in personhood
that means they're not each other
identical in nature so these remember
the two distinctions personhood nature
they're united identical in nature
distinct in their personhood who they
are so when we say nature what is nature
it's it's what they are so like
basically who are they're divine they're
god yes when you say they're god yeah
I'm talking about their divine nature so
for god to be god do you think that like
the trinity is necessary 100% okay So
that's where me like me me like me and
my like Christian friend that's where
we're like you know I think I think you
would agree with me. No because like how
how we say is God is just like let's say
one in one. You guys say one like one in
three or three in one. Okay. So how
about this? According to the Quran,
Allah is nothing like his creation,
right? Are you one person? Yeah, one
person. Is Allah one person? Uh he's
he's one. So he's just like you. But
he's above he's like above. But he's
just like you. He's not. No, cuz a
person we're we're humans. Like I know
you're a human being who is one person
individual. He's a divine being. You you
are too. No, when you say per like
person, he's I'm an individual and he's
an individual. Yeah, but he's the
individual who created. No problem. No
worries. I got you. But just like how
you're a single individual, Allah is a
single individual. He's just like you.
Yeah. But um so wait, wait. I need you
to to rest on that. Yeah. He's
individual. So we're So you're similar
to Allah. No. No. Come on, bro. Allah is
God and but you're but I'm talking about
you're not a creation. You're not a
creation. He No worries. Let's I'm just
I'm talking about I I got you. But I'm
just talking about there's certain
aspects that you are like Allah in. For
example, you are a single person just
like Allah is a single person. But Allah
has hands, right? Allah has uh you know
talking about the to our hands. Yeah. To
our hands. You have hands. No, we're
talking we don't Okay. Do you you
talking human hands? We're talking about
hands. Period. You have hands, right?
Okay. A a clock has a hand. Okay. So
like like Allah a clock has hands too.
No. Okay. But we say hand we don't get
like as a Muslim we don't get into like
we don't like you don't cross that line,
right? But you cross the line with
Christianity. The Christianity
Christianity is like more of like we say
we say we get into the the trinity like
even. Yes. But I'm getting into right
now. Like I have Jewish friends, right?
Me and me me like we say I say a Jew
like like I see a Jew like as more of a
monotheist because that that don't mean
nothing to me, bro. I'm I'm talking
about how you are similar to your God.
When you say that, you know that Allah
is is the creator. He's unlike his
creation. However, when I read the Quran
and I look at you and me, I see a lot of
similarities with Allah and us. He has
hands. We have hands. Whether you say
his hands are unlike what we know, fine.
But he has hands just like I have hands.
He um is one individual person like I'm
one individual person. He's not
completely unique from his creation.
He's completely unique. How? I'm just
naming some creator of all creators.
He's like you see the sky right now. You
see the trees. He's we can we create can
you create a tree? Can you create a You
see those birds down there? Can you
create Jesus? Jesus good. Jesus. Hey,
but with all his permission listen God.
So So you got two creators of life, you
know. Yeah. So with, look, this is my
point. With with Allah's permission, you
have two creators of life. That's no
longer monotheism. Unless how is that
monotheism? Because, okay, if you're all
right, only God can create life. Yeah.
Period. Only God can create life. If
Allah gives somebody else the ability to
create life, he has now created another
God. That's another God now. Has a
miracle. He let somebody do miracle. All
right. So now he's God. He's another
creator of life. Like for example, when
that bird tweets in the morning, Who is
that bird going to praise? Okay, so God
God is the uh what how do I say this?
He's the most high. So he's the most
high. Most high over what? Most high of
everything. Like he over what though?
Over everything. Like everything you
see, he's the most high of all creation.
Right. So when it comes to the the the
the galaxies, the earth, um you know,
the universe. How does that help solve
the two god problem? Because he's the
he's the king of all like kings, bro.
It's like there is no we say God right
here, right? And we say creation and
it's where's Jesus? Jesus. Okay. Jesus
was a prophet. That's what we say. We
don't say a prophet who could create
life. Well, also um what what's his
name? There was a prophet that also, you
know, in the Bible too. Who what there's
a who raised the dead? Elijah. Yeah. And
then there's Yeah, that's what I'm
saying. Like there is but there's but no
prophet created life. There's there's if
he raised a dead like that's God's
permission, you know. deserve. I
understand. But create, we're talking
about creating life, brother. This is a
a divine attribute of God alone. Just
pay attention to this cuz I need you to
to understand the implications. I hear
what you're saying, but there's a key
aspect. All right. So, what what is my
point? What is my point? Your point is
saying if there's two creators of life,
then that means there's two there's two
creators. They're trying to say there's
two gods. We don't say that's two gods.
I know you don't say that, but this is
the conclusion. No, that isn't the
conclusion cuz that's wrong. Because God
is God still. And Jesus. Yes. And Jesus
is a little god now. Not a little God.
Yeah. You have go you have Allah who's
the bigger God. And now he and now he
made Jesus a little God. He's a prophet.
That's what we say. He's a prophet.
That's how that's where we leave it at.
But I know that's where you want to
leave it at. But that's not the
conclusion. That is the conclusion
because we're also every bro I can
create like uh let's you can't create
life. Hey, let's say me like let's say
me and a girl come together, right? How
does the baby get? How do like who lets
who lets the baby in? God does. God
creates that life through through uh you
know the the reproductive system and who
God creates that life. If God if God
doesn't want the baby to be born, he can
say no. Right. There is no baby going to
be created if God doesn't create that
baby in the womb. No. If he doesn't
allow like let's say there has a
miscarriage or some type of thing
happened. Yeah. And God is God
permission like you your heart breathing
right now. Your heart's only breathing
cuz God let your heart of course. So
that's where we that's where we say God
letting you God lets everything but I so
I have the ability to to breathe but but
I'm I'm breathing by God's permission.
He's given me permission to use my
ability to breathe. Right. Yeah. And
he's also So basically like this. So
when Jesus creates the bird, it's he
already has the ability to create the
bird. Now he just got gets Allah's
permission to create. He already has
that ability. He just now uses that
ability when he gets permission to.
Right. Yeah. God gave him that ability.
No, there's different there's a
difference between giving ability versus
giving permission. He gave he gave him
that permission and ability to do that.
All right. Now, the Quran don't say
ability, right? Not ability, but
permission. He gave permission just in
that time and frame when he when God
when know Jesus said, "Oh, God, God,
these people not believing in me. They
don't want to believe in you, God. Send
me a sign to them so I can show them."
That's not what happened. Or something
like that. cuz you know most prophets
you know cuz nobody know when God sends
a prophet the whole message of the
prophet say because the people are lost
they they're losing that never happened
with Jesus brother Jesus Jesus never
complained to that's not a or like how
like in Islam like all of our prophets
uh God sent them uh to you know God sent
them to teach the people of their
nations right cuz the children of Israel
they're uh they're from Moses right
you know God or with Moses he's from the
children of Israel too because Um, you
know, God favored them because like, you
know, the He chose them. Yeah. Yeah. He
chose them cuz the Pharaoh was uh
abusing them and stuff like that. That's
the thing. We have a lot of similarities
with Christianity. Like it's just we
have
like even Jews, the Jews reject Jesus
being a prophet. The the Muslims, we say
he's a prophet, but we don't say he's
God. And we got the Christians. Yeah.
But you call him the Messiah, bro. Yeah.
Because we say he has he's he's the
anointed one to come back. To come back.
Yeah. Where does the Quran say that?
He's he's the Messiah. Messiah means the
anointed one. Yeah. But for what? And we
also have the hadith as well. But okay,
that's good. I'll give you both.
According to the Quran or the Hadith,
why is Jesus the Messiah? What does that
even mean? God chose him. But but uh
look, God chose all those prophets.
Antichrist. There's a specific. Got you.
So Jesus isn't the Messiah until he
defeats the Antichrist. He is. He is.
He's the chosen one. Is is that the is
that the proof? Is that the check box
that makes him the Messiah? Defeating
the Antichrist. To come back. The
person. Okay. So I want you think Jews
also believe in a Messiah as well. I got
you. I got you. You say he's coming
back. Just think think this through with
me. Okay. You're saying that what
signifies Jesus being the Messiah is him
coming back to kill the Antichrist. So
before that, there's nothing that points
to him being the Messiah until the end
time comes and he kills the Antichrist.
Yeah, but he's still cuz at the end he's
still he's going to So my question is
this, why would a Jew believe Jesus when
he says, "Hey guys, I'm the Messiah."
Why would a Jew believe him if he can't
prove he's the Messiah until he comes
beat the Antichrist? Well, he proved
that he was a prophet, though. No,
that's okay. Moses is a prophet. Yeah.
Muhammad a prophet. Yeah. Are they
messiahs? No. Only there's only one
messiah. Very good. So being a prophet
doesn't make you the Messiah. Not only
there's only one Messiah. So Very good.
So follow me. Follow me. Follow me. So
specifically the Messiah. This is a this
is a special identification. Jesus comes
and says, "Hey guys, I'm the Messiah.
Why wouldn't you believe him?"
He he gave them many he gave them many
like you know miracles and he okay how
do you know that being doing miracles is
a checkbox to being the Messiah because
there's you know if you're a regular
human and you see someone doing
supernatural things that means nothing
prophets did that right yeah cuz that
don't make the Messiah though do it the
Messiah you got to cuz Jesus was
truthful people believe so what prophets
were truthful that don't make the
messiah that's why you got to believe
cuz it's for the people who believe
though but why what reason would they
have God chose God chose. How would they
know? If you believe it's all about
belief. No, but no. Listen, brother. The
belief has to be substance. Has to have
uh you know found foundation. It is a So
if God like let's say atheist, right?
They they only say, "Oh, I'm not going
to believe in God until he comes up down
and shows me this." That's what they
say. So it's just you got to it's all by
faith. But but so you're saying you're
what you're describing sounds like blind
faith. Like no evidence. I just believe
off off of the choice to believe. No,
it's not a blind faith. We have many
reasons why we believe. Okay, good. So,
my question is, what is what are the
reasons? What are the check boxes that
um are the evidences for Jesus being the
Messiah? As a Muslim, we go to the
Quran. I know you do. That's what I'm
asking you. Yeah. That's the thing. You
don't I don't believe what you like I
don't believe what you believe and you
don't believe what I believe. So, that's
the thing. Before there was a Quran, was
there was there a term called the
Messiah? Uh was there a Messiah? Is
there was there a concept? Sure. I would
have to I would have Where do you think
the term Messiah comes from? The Quran.
It comes because Jesus said he was a
Messiah. Very good. So if Jesus claims
to be the Messiah, that's 600 years
before a Quran is even thought of,
right? Yeah. So before there's a Quran,
there's no there was injil. Very good.
There's Injil and there's Torah, right?
Okay. So we know that the term Messiah,
this concept comes from the previous
scriptures. So the previous scriptures
will tell you what the Messiah is
supposed to do, who he's supposed to be,
where he's supposed to be from, his
mission, and everything. It'll give you
the check boxes, right? So you don't
find this in the Quran. The Quran just
says Jesus is the Messiah without
telling you how. You need to go to the
previous scriptures to learn how and
why. It doesn't say that. What doesn't
say that? In Islam, we don't say we have
to go back to the It says It says It
says to affirm. Like
hold on a second, brother. You done, you
done hit my topic. Now, you you I'm
wrong. I'm wrong, bro. This is the
argument he gave when we first talked to
her. Cook, bro. This is chapter 10,
verse 94. If you want to. So, if you
Muhammad are in doubt concerning that
which you have revealed to you, that
your name is written in the Torah. No,
that's that's brackets. Forget the
brackets. Then ask those who are reading
the book, the Torah and the angels, the
gospel before you. Verily truth has come
to you from your Lord. So be not of
those who doubt. Right? So according to
this verse, it says, "So if you if you
are in doubt concerning that which we
have revealed to you," meaning the
Quran, right? Cuz that came to Muhammad,
right? Yeah. So if you're doubting the
Quran, what does Allah tell Muhammad to
do? He says, "Go and ask those who've
been reading the scripture before you."
Truly the truth has come to you from
your Lord. So do not doubt. So Allah
tells Muhammad, bro, if you're doubting
the Quran, if you're doubting what I'm
revealing to you in the Quran, go check
the previous scriptures. The Quran
literally says that you got to do this.
Uh I think you debated uh somebody on
this topic. Who was it? Um a lot of
people on this. Yeah. Yeah. I use this.
Okay. Let's say a knowledgeable Muslim.
Like what was their answer? A Muslim.
No, I can't I can't give you the right
answer for that. There is none. But I'll
tell you what they say. I'll give you
their responses. Their response would be
Yeah. So their response is uh would be
uh well Muhammad didn't doubt. So it
only says if he doubted he didn't he
never doubted. That's what their
response would be. My argument isn't
that Muhammad doubted. My argument is
what does Allah tell him to do if he
doubts? And so it says go to the
previous scriptures. Another response
they'll say is, "Oh, well, this is
talking about specific things." Like in
this chapter when it refers to the
stories of the prophets or whatever,
it's checking those specific things, not
everything. That's what they would say.
The Quran doesn't say that. Okay? But
even if I were to grant that, let's say
it only is saying check these these
things on this particular topic, you
still got to go to the Bible. It still
tells them to do that. So
there's no answer. Yeah, that that's
that's something that I would have to I
can't give you the answer. There is no
answer. I'm just showing you what the
Quran says. I don't have to look into
this cuz I heard this like I I really
when I hear this argument, I just go
past it. Like, you know, I just cuz I
didn't really cuz I didn't have a Muslim
really talk about like cuz when a Muslim
and a Christian are debating, they
debate the Trinity. They debate the the
the Bible is corrupted. They debate um
they debate Jesus uh
me this is one of the new like this is I
know uh uh Avery this is one of your
main you know points that you got uh it
is you know you you're I see how your
point how you come across that point but
I don't have an answer for that so it's
okay so so so this is what my conclusion
with this is that because the Quran is
telling us to go back to the previous
scriptures we got to do that if we're
going to if we let the Quran speak Let's
do what the Quran says. We go check the
Bible. There's also there's also a verse
in the Quran um that says um pre affirm
affirm affirm like the the previous it
confirms it confirms the Quran confirms
and it talks about the the it talks
about verses being changed. It never
does. It never does. It says that they
distort with their mouths. It says they
cons they try to conceal the truth.
Allah's they distort Allah's um words
but with their tongue. Yeah. That's 378.
I'm not sure if it says in writing or
not, but I got to look it up. There
there's one verse that they that that a
lot of people try to go to. We've been
doing a whole live stream on this, bro.
Um they they try to go to 279 where it
says, "Woe to those who write the
scripture with their own hand claiming
that it's from God." Okay, good. And so,
and this and this is why that one
doesn't work because it says, "Wo to
those who write the book with their own
hands." So, right, actually before that,
it says, matter of fact, let's go to it.
You want to see it and then we'll um I
don't want to keep it too long, but
yeah, I'm about to I'm about to go right
now. All right. So, let me just show you
how this doesn't work. Okay,
278. I'm going show you why this is this
is silly. And so, I never want you to
make this argument cuz you'll look
silly. Okay, don't do that. I care about
you. Let's read the verse
before. So, it says verse 78. And there
are among them unlettered people who
know not the book, but they trust upon
false desires and they but guess. Then
then woe to those who write the book
with their own hands and then say this
is from Allah to purchase with it a
little price. Woe to them for what their
hands have written and to what they and
and toh for what they earn. Read this
verse right here that comes out there.
And they say the fire uh the fire skip
the brackets shall not touch us but for
a few numbered days. say, "Have you
taken a covenant from Allah so that
Allah will not break his covenant? Or is
it that you say of Allah what you know
not?" So basically, you have these
people, they don't know the book.
They're unlettered. They don't know the
scripture. Then it says, "Woe to those
who write the book with their own
hands." They don't know the scripture,
so they can't change what they don't
know. They're writing fake books
claiming it's from God. They don't know
the actual scripture. You know what I'm
saying? So the Torah is still intact.
the gospel still intact. There's also
another verse that say the Quran is the
final revelation. It never says that. It
never says that the Quran is the final
revelation. The the the book of truth it
says what came before. Exactly. So it
says the Torah and the gospel is book of
truth as well and in them are guidance
and light. They were like we say at one
point in time I know you say but the
Quran never says that that stops. Matter
of fact look it literally says let's
still in chapter 2 let's go to the let's
go a few verses before we'll go to verse
41. Watch what it says in verse 41. It
says, "Oh,
oh, look. It says, "And believe in what
I have sent down, confirming that which
is with you." Right? Confirming that
which with you, the Torah, the first to
and and the gospel. And do not be the
first to disbelieve when they get not
from my verses, the Torah. Oh, it says
it right here. Mhm.
Uh not the first to disbelieve therein
and buy get the Torah and the angelic
gospel by selling verses fear me and so
notice how this verse says that the
Quran came down confirming that which is
with them. So what they have is true.
The Quran is saying the Torah and his
gospel it's true even in Muhammad's
time. So this idea that the Quran says
that they're corrupted is silliness.
They're lying about what the Quran says,
bro. They're doing what the what they're
accusing Christians of doing, distorting
the words of the Quran. So this this is
this is why I said this is the biggest
this is the biggest argument that I have
against Islam or Muslims when they come.
The the Quran affirms the Bible over and
over again, bro. But we don't say the
jail is the Bible. I know you don't. We
we never The angel is the gospel that
was with Jesus. Even when you go even
when you like do your research when you
go like is the jail the Bible that we
don't say the jail is the Bible. Well,
what is it then? And if it's not in jail
is what was what was with the Jesus.
What was that? And that was the angel.
That was just basically the angel. That
was the I know, bro. When you say the
Bible is not the angel, that means that
you know what the angel actually is
then. So what was it? Cuz we don't Okay.
We don't have um the actual We don't
have the actual angel. Very good. So
you're saying you don't you don't have
the actual angel. Let's either got lost
in time or something. So then how do you
know that the Bible isn't it? Because we
we put it in we we go to the what the
Quran and the hadith says. Where does it
where does the Quran reject? It
literally says that they have it. No, it
says it says it doesn't talk about the
Bible. It talks about the It says the
Injil the Gospel is not the the Bible.
The Bible is a collection of books. And
what is and what is in that collection
of books? Torah. There's a Torah. Psalms
gospel. In the There's a title called
There's a book called the Gospel,
brother. Uh we got a Bible. Yeah. Right
here. Right. Yeah. Yeah. Oh, here it is.
There's a book called There's a There's
a chapter called the Gospel, dude.
Look, man. I never heard a gospel. Look,
like a chapter. I'm not talking like
right I'm I'm I'm showing you collection
of books. The gospel. So, this is the
gospel of Jesus according to Mark. So,
basically Mark wrote it. It's the gospel
of Jesus that Mark wrote his account,
right? He literally starts out by saying
this, the beginning of the gospel of
Jesus Christ, the son of God. We have
the gospel, bro. And then they start
telling the gospel.
Okay. So you say this this ma like what
is this? This this is this is Mark what
is like is this so so Mark is writing an
account of the gospel. So Mark writes an
account of the gospel. Matthew also
writes an account of the gospel. Luke
and John all four these four authors
they write an account of the gospel of
Jesus. Okay. Who who are these uh like
um so Mark is what would have been is an
apostle who is writing his account at
the dictation of Peter. So Peter, who is
a direct apostle of Jesus, right? You
know who Peter is, Simon Peter. Yeah. He
was walking around with Jesus, talking
with him whoop, and he's telling Mark
the gospel and Mark's writing it down
for him. Luke went, he was also an
apostle around with Paul and them. And
he interviewed the disciples of Jesus
and the eyewitnesses and wrote a gospel
account according to what they told him.
John is a direct apostle of Jesus and so
is Matthew. Matthew used to be a tax
collector, but Jesus called him and
said, "Follow me. I got a Bible. We got
a um like uh there's D people at my
mosque. They they have the Bible and
they do their own research on like you
know the how to like how these people
party. Um I don't know what they say cuz
I don't I don't really read the Bible
like that. But um I know they had like
arguments of like they have like um they
have like highlighters and stuff like
that. That means nothing to me. But you
do they live out here? No. No. I'm from
I'm not from here. I'm from Minnesota,
man. Okay. I'm just down here selling
panels. Okay. Nice. All right. Nice
talking to you. You too, bro. You, too.
It was a pleasure meeting you. But look,
look at Do not let this like just go.
Think seriously about this. Um, I'm I'm
going to look through this. I'm going to
go look um everything up. The the
the Quran, the Bible. Yeah, that's
that's important. I want you to look
that up. I'm going to look it up. I'm
going to search up like the actual
answer for this cuz I got You just tell
me what cuz I I never Look, I'm going to
tell you what they say. Trust me, I'm
not a prophet. I'm going to tell you
what they're going to tell you. Okay. as
you how you you debated like what is all
of them. I debate all the top guys that
you can think of. I've I've talked to
them. They have no answer for this. I'm
telling you, we literally are doing a
live stream series on the we call it the
Islamic dilemma. Okay. How the Quran
affirms the Bible. We've been doing a
live stream on this for the past 2 three
weeks. I got to watch it. I I'm not I
came across your channel. I I came
across your TikTok live. Okay. When I
see clips of you and uh Libyan Well,
we're going to do it Friday. On Friday.
Watch the stream on Friday. Make sure
you guys watch it on God Logic. We're
going to be on YouTube. We're big ass TV
in our Oh, good. Perfect. Have a watch
party. We're going to We're going to be
inviting all the big Muslims. We did it
last week. We did it just Friday. None
of them came. They won't come. Who are
they? Like we're we're Shikman, uh,
Orthodox Muslim, uh, Dean responds,
Hamza's Den, all those guys here or is
it online? Yeah, online. We're doing a
stream, a live stream. We're inviting
them to come and answer this question
about the Quran affirming the Bible.
Come refute us. That's what we're That's
the challenge. Okay. And so I want you
to watch Friday. We're going to be using
the Quran. Anybody confirmed though? No,
nobody is. It's it's just an open invite
and we we keep everybody keep I think
somebody like if it's a live stream like
on like anybody can come. It's going to
be on YouTube. Anybody can tune in on
YouTube. Hit the link and join the
discussion. Okay. I'm going be I'm Yeah.
Tune in. Ask like when you first start
asked that question. I want to see how
they like answer. Of course. Yeah. I I
promise you none of them are going to
show up though. They won't show up. They
not going to show up. Wait, how did the
confession with Dean go? With Dean last
time you debated him? Oh. Oh, Dean Dean
thinks that uh he says D and Jill's the
New Testament.
Hey man, I'm I'm going look into I I
used to be watching YouTube debates and
stuff like that. But me and him we we
met on this app. We used to debate
you everybody you debate Liv.
Yeah, I debate I've debated uh Dean
before, but when I was new, so he kind
of could. He kind of got you. Yeah, he
could be a little deceptive, but it's
all good. None of them can answer this.
This is a problem for all of them. So
that's what I'm saying. It's cool. It's
cool. Yeah. All right, bro.
Oh my god. Logic.
[Music]